this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app all the
babies use the cash app which is why
it's the number one finance app in the
App Store and now the cash card is more
powerful than ever with cash apps latest
feature cash boost download the cash app
get your free cash card and select your
boost save money when you swipe on stuff
like coffee
Chipotle Shake Shack and more download
the free cash app for iOS or Android now
[Laughter]
[Music]
the a little bit early this way so
download nordic chris d'elia go to where
we get an app and then write in
crystally an app will come up you'll see
it and download that someone was saying
that while I was off because I was on
the app a little bit before we started
recording that it was awkward because I
wasn't doing anything else I stand by it
I've said it before on this podcast man
things are only awkward if you're
awkward that's the kind of thing that
[ __ ] doesn't exist unless you're
awkward when people are like ah you're
this is awkward
Oh woah you're just being an awkward
person you're an awkward person I'm
chilling when I do meet and greets at my
shows afterwards people are like how
this is so awkward for you ha I say no
it's awkward for you I'm [ __ ] used to
it take the pic take the pic oh wow I'm
sure you hate this don't you nah uh I'm
getting paid is this your least favorite
part what was making money my least
favorite part of life from not making
money some favorite parts of life but
yeah dude episodes what 72 what the [ __ ]
is it 72 dude you know what I did the
atlast podcast I said stoled and I said
I stole a hat and this is why I did that
because that's what the [ __ ] word
should be [ __ ] this stolen [ __ ] we
changing the way the English language
goes just
because it's sound what what [ __ ] was
like now I going to call it stolen not
stowed even though edy is usually past
tense for everything so hi guys this is
it we doing it and it's episode 72 and I
was in New Jersey I was in New York a
little bit hanging out I did a Poppins
show I popped in I did the Gotham comedy
club was really fun
then I did New Jersey I was in Red Bank
that was awesome and then I was in
Delaware I'd never been to Delaware
which I guess was the first state ever
it's like I give a [ __ ] about that
people kept telling me he's the first
state ever are cool I'm [ __ ] 38 not
785 so it doesn't [ __ ] matter to me
you know what I mean
everybody wants tradition and [ __ ]
how how nice and how how oh yeah but oh
yeah but this matters because of that
happened and [ __ ] no it matters because
all right cool history matters as much
as where you go like this okay cool and
then we're gonna repeat the [ __ ] anyway
so anyway we're all going down in flames
catch you later
[Music]
so I was in Delaware and then I went to
Pennsylvania at a place called reading
which is spelled reading so therefore
call it reading or change it to our EDD
ing and that's it that's it that's it
that's how it goes not trying to confuse
the foreigners had some fun shows man
they were really good shows I had some
really good shows I brought two openers
I had my buddy mark the Irish guy who
[ __ ] god dammit man we really need to
either send him back to Ireland or clean
up his [ __ ] language dude the guy he
does my biggest pet peeve it's my
biggest pet peeve dude when somebody
says something and then you say what and
then they don't say what they said they
say something else no if you say
something and then I asked what you
repeat the exact same [ __ ] thing a
lot of people will just repeat the
second half of it they'll be like well
here's what happened we were driving
back to my house from the airport we had
a driver and the guy was driving back to
the airport driving us back to from the
airport to my house and Mark my Irish
buddy
lives in between there and we were
driving by his place we was like he said
to the driver in his [ __ ] up Irish
accent was it by the way this is
annoying even if you don't have a crazy
accent wherever you are he said oh you
can drop me off anywhere I hear a boss
and he didn't say it loud enough because
first of all he doesn't talk loud enough
and second of all he's Irish his [ __ ] so
you heard it wasn't even like as clear
as I said it he says something like you
don't have anywhere to hear boss and
then the driver said what and then Mark
said anywhere boss and the driver kept
driving rightfully so I like my driver
and he keeps [ __ ] driving because
Mark didn't do what he was supposed to
do which was to be second the second
time you say something if somebody says
what be more clear and maybe even say
more things you don't just say a lot of
people do the second half of the
sentence they'll be like oh man I'm
really hungry did you want to eat
somewhere oh man I'm really hungry where
do you wanna go they say what is that
what do you want to go they say what
we're I want to go where what would he
talk about shopping to the pool oh no no
I said it was hungry where you gonna go
oh you're hungry okay that changes
everything then that [ __ ] changes
everything then man I most likely didn't
hear the first part of what you said
because you caught me off guard talking
we weren't having a conversation then
they say some [ __ ] I say what and I got
a ketchup list and and then you read the
second half are you a done stood say the
whole [ __ ] sentence or say more
obviously these are the [ __ ] this is
it this is how it should be and there's
my biggest pet peeve so he says anywhere
boss and the driver keeps driving he
doesn't say what again because that's on
[ __ ] mark dude and that's cool
another thing about Mark is when he says
his [ __ ] name to people
marek that's how they say in Ireland
Marek and people are like what America
did you say mark when I go to [ __ ]
Spain guess what my name is now could he
stole baht that's what it is
um so so I go so so he doesn't say [ __ ]
and I say hey mark repeat what you said
he doesn't know what you just said
anywhere
that's all you [ __ ] said he doesn't
know what anywhere means I said this in
the car I was like repeat what you just
[ __ ] said and he says oh you can drop
yeah I said he wants you to drop him off
here anywhere he said that's okay and
he's not doing it right
and the driver said oh okay cool I said
sorry man he's [ __ ] doesn't speak up
and we've been over this and he draw any
pulled over and toss him out and he left
dude that tries to be nuts when people
do that you ever see that show you did
you see American Idol last night what
last night huh huh you could have said
did you get [ __ ] in the ass last night
well I don't know last night uh uh
repeat the whole [ __ ] thing dude I
swear to God do that if you listen to
this podcast and you don't do that dude
I don't want you listening to this
podcast man that really drives me nuts
dude you most likely didn't hear the
first part so anyway I brought him and
then my other guy Mike I brought him to
open for me too and I called them my
openers cuz I think it's funny cuz like
their lives are so easy anyway they get
to play these [ __ ] cool crowds and
[ __ ] and like I was give him [ __ ] I'm
like your life's too good we basically
have the same life me and them because
we're just like rolling around doing all
the same [ __ ] and even though like
quote-unquote they're like at the
beginning of their career and like but
they still like [ __ ] have the same
life I do we eat at night diners we
laugh so hard you know what I mean we
left so hard dude we laughed so hard all
we do is laugh so hard and make fun of
each other and laugh so hard dude it's
the best life man I love my [ __ ] life
um so do it I it's just [ __ ] awesome
took some flights man the the you know
what's [ __ ] man you pay for these
flights and like if you put the hard
never mind that's gonna be such a
[ __ ] first world problem I'm not even
going to talk about that but I was in
New York and I was staying in the Lower
East Side had a good time
I liked the Lower East Side III don't
know man I was having a good time in New
York and and reading I like one places
just for one night you know what I mean
because you can like even if you're in a
[ __ ] like I guess reading is a
[ __ ] I don't know if it is or not
you don't know you don't know you're
there for [ __ ] nine hours you don't
know if it's a piece of [ __ ] or not you
know I was in Delaware Delaware seemed
like I had nothing to [ __ ] do there
but I didn't know I just went and got
some coffee and chilled out um by the
way I get good at I'm good at like cuz
people when I walk down the street
especially like near my shows people be
like crews and I'm good at like not
turning around because then that means I
have to [ __ ] and like talk to them and
have a whole conversation with them and
[ __ ] but pretty soon like somebody's
gonna like be like walking up to me to
rob me or like shoot me and somebody's
gonna go Chris and I'm not gonna turn
around they're just gonna blow my
[ __ ] brains out so that's cool
thanks several one else's fault not mine
dude I I realized something about me
recently I [ __ ] blame everything on
everybody else and I gotta get that [ __ ]
together
straight up I blame everything on
everybody else
so here's it great here's a great [ __ ]
example here's a great example
alright so I was I I got these [ __ ] I
air pods right which are great Mac makes
them now they're entirely too small of
course you're gonna lose him when you
buy them nobody thinks when you buy them
nobody doesn't think oh [ __ ] I better
not lose these cuz they're the size of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] head okay they're the size
of a [ __ ] the bell end of a [ __ ] head
all right and so you're like [ __ ] and by
the way it's the air pods they're the
smallest [ __ ] thing with two smaller
things inside of them none of this [ __ ]
is connected you gonna lose at least one
of those [ __ ] pieces you're gonna
lose the box or one of the ears or one
of the [ __ ] you know what I mean like
Apple is just like a you know apples
like if we can't wait for [ __ ]
to lose these we want to see we want to
keep track of how many people are buying
the shits cuz I already bought two okay
they slid out of my [ __ ] dude
here's the other thing oh wow we're good
we're [ __ ] off and running pants hey
pants have pockets that only are [ __ ]
horizontal to the ground dude don't make
pockets that are perpendicular to the
[ __ ] ground you know that khaki pants
and [ __ ] do you know what I'm talking
about when you sit down everything falls
out of your [ __ ] pocket oh oh
sideways pocket sideways pockets [ __ ] my
ass dude no no dude pockets go straight
across like some closed eyelids that's
what happens man that's it this way
unless you're doing backflips [ __ ]
doesn't fall out of your pants and if
you're doing backflips you deserve to
lose [ __ ] everything by the way you
know some people some [ __ ] you know
you've seen people do backflips in
public those people are real
[ __ ] do they deserve to drop it
they deserve to lose coins earpods
wallets everything so I am now I am now
I have the the air pods and in my rider
which and a rider is what the
quote-unquote artist not quote what the
artist wants in his green room before
the show okay
like whether it's a musician or a
magician or a you know whether it's a
musician or a magician kill yourself or
a comedian right so now if you're a
musician you get a writer if you're a
magician
you know cope you get a writer and if
you're a comedian you get a right
okay now a lot of people have crazy [ __ ]
like people are like oh well Prince had
only green M&Ms cuz you want you know
whatever the [ __ ] you hear all these
stories and [ __ ] some guys get like I
heard TJ Miller gets a [ __ ] slot he
won't he has quote unquote
a sloppy turkey sandwich or some [ __ ] I
got basic [ __ ] in mind I got club soda
Tabasco sauce
[ __ ] salmon and oh a toothbrush with
toothpaste cuz I'm like that sometimes I
just I think I gotta brush my teeth I
can't do anything until I brush my teeth
I'm a crazy [ __ ] okay so so I so
I have the toothpaste and the toothbrush
in my Ryder and my opener Mike always
steals it from me because he likes to be
like oh well I like to take it and bring
it back and my roommates we all got
[ __ ] toothpaste and toothbrushes out
the wazoo and I'm like dude I like to
keep them
don't steal them from me they're [ __ ]
mine okay now the the this theater in
Redding decided to also get me dental
floss all right now
goddamn this story has so many layers
it's like a [ __ ] horror movie so back
up months ago Mike my opener said that
my air pods
he hates them because he always thinks
that their dental floss so as a joke I
went online to see if they sell dental
floss stickers and they do and I bought
them and I put them on my air pod thanks
so they looked like dental floss it
looked more like there because it said
air pod dental floss it was like a cute
thing that somebody made on [ __ ]
Pinterest was the only thing I ever
[ __ ] saw on Pinterest so by the way
Pinterest stop [ __ ] emailing me every
week I don't have you all right so so
now I have the air pods and I have the
air and I have the NI and I have this
this toothpaste and toothbrush and floss
in my Rider and I take it because
don't want him to [ __ ] take it and I
put it in my hotel room now as I'm
leaving reading I'm getting all my [ __ ]
together
and I'm like oh [ __ ] this dental floss
and I put the glide dental floss on the
on the bathroom counter and I take the
[ __ ] toothpaste and I take the the
the toothbrush and I put it in my bag
and then I realized this now but I
subconsciously see the air pods also not
in the bathroom but I and I and I
subconsciously feel that those are the
that that's the the dental floss that
I'm leaving okay so as I'm leaving
reading going to the airport I realize
[ __ ] not only did I leave the
dental floss but I also left my air pods
I'm not going back because I'm already
at the airport almost and it's like an
hour away so now this is only my fault I
realize that but sacredly I also think
that it is the first of all I asked for
toothpaste and a toothbrush I did not
ask for dental floss so I want to blame
the venue I'm mad now at the venue for
giving me dental floss because I think
well if they didn't give me the [ __ ]
dental floss I would still have my ear
pods on me I wouldn't subconsciously
thought that there was the dental floss
so I'm genuinely angry at the venue and
I'm like getting pissed off like this
[ __ ] venue trying to help too much
just give me the [ __ ] toothpaste and
the toothbrush that's all I want why
give me [ __ ] I didn't ask for right
and I'm getting angry and then I think
you know what it's all so [ __ ] Mike's
fault because this [ __ ] always
tries to steal my toothpaste and [ __ ]
and I had to make sure and keep it and
because I took it back I probably would
have forgot it if I wasn't for him
because I wanted to him to not have it
so I would have I wouldn't have thought
it was my the the the the dental floss
in the [ __ ] in in in my in my in my
hotel room and I would I had the air
pods on me not only that I wouldn't even
a got the air potsticker if it wasn't
for Mike getting all pissed off because
he thought that the dent that the
[ __ ] air pods were dental floss so
I'm like [ __ ] him he made me get the
sticker he made me make it think it was
dental floss and now subconsciously I
thought it was dental floss and in my
head even though it's my fault and I
know it deep down secretly it's the
venues
thought and it's Mike's fault that I
lost shows and both of those
[ __ ] owe me new air pods are
$150 and that's how I do it and that's
how I [ __ ] do it dude and that's a
huge problem with me that's a
shortcoming but also [ __ ] these
[ __ ] dude I need to [ __ ] their
they know what I need to do is [ __ ]
their [ __ ] that's what I need to do I
need to find out who [ __ ] start it I
need to fart fart out I need to fart out
I need to find out who [ __ ] said
whose idea was who the runner was to get
me my toothpaste and toothbrush and
reading and I need to [ __ ] roll up on
their crib and [ __ ] their [ __ ] do it
that's right you try to give me some
[ __ ] flossing submit to floss and
then I got to go to Mike's house and I
have to wait till he gets a girlfriend
and then [ __ ] his [ __ ] dude I gotta
[ __ ] their [ __ ] dude for making me
lose my air pots gotta [ __ ] the [ __ ]
yeah to park laughs um I like my uncle
Richard period my uncle Richard laughs
like this and to park laughs like this
and me and my brother always say that to
Park laughs like my uncle Richard and
that's it case closed my head is pod now
um yeah dude I'll aw I lost those air
pods and it's all my [ __ ] openers
faults and the and then I do that though
do it and that's a shortcoming and I
know it I want nothing to be mine I
swear to God I could spill soda and it
alone and be like well [ __ ] for
[ __ ] sake man why'd they make this
table like this it's true you think that
I'm like that yeah I'm on fire coming in
with some [ __ ] hot [ __ ] like he's not
one fired dude let me tell you what one
fire is also at life one fire is not
only one fire here one fire is one fire
at life he forgot his glasses and he's
wearing prescription sunglasses like a
[ __ ] black eye at a nightclub
that's what he's doing right now he's
wearing and he's wearing [ __ ]
sunglasses indoors like his name is
Sergio and he's a black eye at a
nightclub dude how much would a black
eye named Sergio we're not we're [ __ ]
sunglasses at a nightclub dude [ __ ] that
[ __ ] by the way the video podcast is
gonna work this week Ivan get rid of
[ __ ] that off so hard man
and it's all good dude we're gonna have
fuck-ups we're gonna have you know but
I'll tell you who's never gonna have a
[ __ ] me cuz it's always everyone
else's fault it's always everyone else's
fault man ah dude everybody is sending
me DMS and snapchats and [ __ ] and all
the [ __ ] about [ __ ] people and
they're all going cuz I didn't realize
that was gonna be such a hit dude the
vote the the robots the hydraulics bro
forget it I was thinking about robots
actually though would you
I wonder I think what is gonna happen
when we have robots is that people are
becoming gonna become more [ __ ]
they're gonna become more actual pieces
of [ __ ] because because what's gonna
happen is we're gonna have robots that
work for us and we're going to we're not
going to be polite to robots we're not
going to be polite to them robots are
going to be like would you like a turkey
sandwich and we're gonna be like yeah
make me a [ __ ] turkey sandwich do it
bot head or whatever the the the the
slang is the the racist slang is for
robots you know do it [ __ ] tin face
yes just a queer man is Scott's Eclair
turkeys a choir Roy just here's your
turkey sandwich thanks tin head [ __ ] boy
bot face and you're not gonna my point
is you're not gonna be polite you're not
gonna say yes please or thank you to
robot you're gonna be like cool yeah
that's what I want come on hurry up bot
so you're gonna become this more kind of
privileged piece of [ __ ] and then it's
gonna bleed over into real life for sure
there's no way
you're gonna be at a restaurant and
people who aren't working at robe that
one aren't robots they're actually
humans maybe like where's my [ __ ]
turkey sandwich you're gonna adopt that
and it's going to be like that in real
life and it's gonna [ __ ] up the world
because of that now my point my question
is do you think because I think that we
should I think about being polite to
robots I think that we should be polite
to robots because I realize thinking
about this being polite to rope being
polite to someone isn't necessarily for
someone else it's for you dude it's for
you to make sure and keep you in check
and keep you as a nice person and I
think that because of that we need to
still be polite when we start having AI
Wow thank you so much bot that really
felt good thank you for that massage
you're welcome not hey that massage cool
now make me my [ __ ] turkey sandwich
cuz it's gonna bleed over to real life
but no we're gonna be such from other
[ __ ] and everyone's gonna kill each
other that's what I think is gonna
happen because otherwise if your shitty
two robots they guess what's gonna
happen two robots are gonna start
playing this [ __ ]
[Music]
this is robots right here dancing at the
club doing the robot we taking over one
we taking over one city at a time one
city at a time
I don't know man it's weird how much I
love putting music on this podcast even
though how much I don't cause it's cool
even know how much I don't like the
music look at that baby icon aye aye
I was so Kanye came out with the album
and then b.o.b or way who is the other
guy Kid Cudi
I don't know who's who anymore and
everyone dude let me just imagine going
to a [ __ ] first of all imagine flying
to a listening party ah dude no concert
sure now daddy doesn't like concerts but
gets it
you like concerts you coud go everyone
has a little bit of coot in them a
listening party hey jump off a boat and
let the boat leave starve in the ocean
or get eaten by sharks
that's all that's what I need you to do
dude did you go to a listening party I
just need you to take a flight to the
desert in Africa or the jungle no the
jungle in Africa take a flight to Africa
then get on one of those [ __ ] half
car half Jeeps drive out into the jungle
of Africa and tell the other person who
drove that half car half Jeep to leave
and then either starve to death or get
mauled by lions okay
hey come on dude a listening party are
you a [ __ ] person wait till it comes
out by the way comes out the next day
comes out that day I don't know flying
all over the place to go listen to
[ __ ] music with kim kardashian uh is
this a dream that's a dream I mean I
don't mean in a good way
that's just like yeah last night I
[ __ ] flew to Wyoming and like Kim
Kardashian was there and we were
listening to [ __ ] the new Kanye West
album that was that was around a bonfire
oh dude this is the hey this is Earth
dude this isn't [ __ ] this isn't a
dream this is Earth I mean what are you
doing dude
imagine [ __ ] packing up a backpack in
a suitcase to go and listen to a CD did
the other day Mike my opener said a CD
he said ah man it's a good CD and we
[ __ ] roasted him for it like it's
1992 oh it's a CD you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
dude if I ever am at a listening party
saw my [ __ ] nuts off saw my nuts off
hey dude Chris D'Elia here if you're
ever at if you ever catch me at a
listening party saw my nuts off i
[ __ ] [ __ ] it up that thing doesn't
start over goddamn [ __ ] soundboard
[ __ ] [ __ ] this intern dude I know one
fire says it'll be better next week
you'll still be [ __ ] looking like Ray
Charles with his [ __ ] sunglasses
indoors like a guy named Sergio at a
nightclub so funny to think about a guy
named Sergio at a nightclub dude there
isn't somebody would be more at a
nightclub than a guy named Sergio what
is that name anyway is that Russian what
the [ __ ] is it Sergio
that could be anything you could tell me
that South American you could tell me
it's from [ __ ] Penguins came up with
it in Antarctica Spanish you could tell
me it's anything dude you could be like
Sergio was made in the [ __ ] Swiss
Alps you could tell me that name could
be original originated anywhere ancient
Roman course it is isn't everything by
the way I was like [ __ ] 35 before I
realized that the movie uh gladiator
they didn't speak English back then like
in that time and I was like what kind of
bitch-ass [ __ ] is this make it in the
real language
I know it's movies and you could take
the liberties but still dude one of the
things that bothers me the most is when
people say like oh the movies so good
cuz it's so realistic oh shut the [ __ ]
up dude shut up that's not what makes a
good movie cuz it's realistic some of
the greatest filmmakers of all time they
don't make realistic movies my favorite
living director David Lynch never made a
real movie in his [ __ ] life dude
Stanley Kubrick not real at all Fellini
not real the only person that I loved
one of my favorite directors of all time
John Cassavetes in that [ __ ] was a lot
of real [ __ ] but dude it doesn't mean
all right so realistic and then they
take movies that aren't supposed to be
realistic and they're like are they made
it realistic like that's a good mark of
what a lesser mark about a good movie is
like oh yeah I love the Batman because
it was realistic
oh yeah it's about a superhero with a
cape that has gadgets that aren't
invented and won't be invented until the
year 3000 and 12 therefore oh really oh
the horror movie was so good because it
was realistic oh really now make a
horror movie like a horror movie make a
horror movie and like a horror movie
dude right
speaking of heart well you know what I'm
gonna [ __ ] actually do these ads here
you guys listen cuz you're real babies
here we go
post mates ah love it as usual your
stomach and the rest of your life for at
war you need to eat but you can't stop
doing what you're doing to deal with it
and the only fast things that deliver
are not what you want that's how it's
been
however post mates fix that the app that
adds every delivery option to your
favorite restaurants imagine anything
you want to eat go ahead imagine it now
imagine it delivered you don't have to
drive park or even talk on the phone to
order just download the app and order 24
hours a day 365 days a year
post mates will bring you what you want
within the hour you can even see where
your food is and track your driver I use
it daily you forget eggs you forget to
get eggs and milk no problem craving a
tasty burger check looking for the
perfect bottle of red wine right wine or
a summer beer or order up post mates is
your new longtime munchies booty call I
use it almost every day pretty much
every day I use it it's great it's the
app I use I've tried all of them and I
stick with post mates for a limited time
post mates is giving you $100 of free
delivery credit for your first seven
days to start your free deliveries
download the app today and use code
Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit to your first 7 days
save the hassle get the food you love
fast at post mates with code Congrats
Square cash if you haven't heard we're
switching to the cash up if you haven't
heard you're not a true baby you don't
listen to these episode episode because
we live we use square cash we we
switched to the cash app it's the number
one ranked app in the finance in in the
finance world and lets you do the most
with your money would it whether you
want to pay people back by cell Bitcoin
deposit your paycheck right into the app
or order a free custom cash card to
spend anywhere you like and now the cash
card is more powerful than ever with
cash apps latest feature cash boost
the cast the cash cards boost program
lets you get instant discounts every
time you swipe your card right now you
can get a dollar off every purchase you
made at coffee shops across the country
when you pay with your cash card now
that's good everybody likes to save
money to save money are using this it
doesn't stop there discounts 15% off at
Chipotle 50% off at Shake Shack and
that's just some of the stuff of course
when you download the cash app and enter
rewards code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund so listen to me
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now oh man we got our oh by the
way we tried to show you guys the
YouTube plaque last time but I won't get
rid of messed it all up so here it is
there's the plaque for 100,000
subscribers very cool thanks YouTube
what's IHOP changed it to International
House of burgers they just changed their
whole [ __ ] might as well be Electronics
did you see what Wendy's did they were
like hey Wendy's are you nervous about
what I have there eat self burgers now
and Wendy's was like no they this is
from the company that thought [ __ ]
making pancakes was too hard
[Music]
Wendy's doesn't [ __ ] around you dude who
runs Wendy's Twitter ja Rule
I was I was reading about this guy
except by the way extension you know how
everyone calls him extension the rapper
you know it's xxx 10 ASEAN that's how
you pronounce his name
xxx 10th ASEAN they asked him when he
was is actually xxs 10th St on first of
all no it's extension my hey that's it
my hands died now go to lunch alright
that's it
but this guy look they try to separate
the music from the artists I get it he's
done some awful [ __ ] apparently you know
there's pictures of like his girlfriend
that just bludgeoned and like her I
either read like from bleeding and [ __ ]
I mean the guy just like beats the [ __ ]
out of women and like you know I guess
it's all alleged at this point but it's
like Jesus Christ women don't really
make this stuff up not this stuff at
least so this this article came out that
this intern wrote apparently for I don't
know what company or news source but she
went to his house and just interviewed
him and he was like yeah come on in
and the guy's just like such a flaring
piece of [ __ ] I had no idea and trying
to separate the artists from the music
the music I listened to some of his
music because I wanted to see what the
[ __ ] hype was about and it's really
good dude and it sucks that like it's
weird like I always thought like as an
artist you know like you own half the
[ __ ] you create because you created and
then the audience takes what they take
from it you know but it's [ __ ] it's
crazy because they tried to pull it from
Spotify and then but but he wasn't
convicted or anything so I think they
put it back
like his fans went to war for him like
they showed up at the girl he beats work
and like we're being like threatening
and creepy to her and this is awful it's
awful it's what it's what's wrong with
the world now with the Internet and then
and then we're glorifying these [ __ ]
idiotic rappers but there is feeling and
emotion behind his songs and it's not
just about you know money and cars and
[ __ ]
it's just weird but people are like well
what do we do do we do we do we make it
so we can't listen to his music no well
I think what you do is you make first of
all you can victim of these [ __ ]
crimes and then yeah and then you you
know you're not allowed to I don't care
if you're good at making music you don't
get to do that if those are the things
that you do you know like you don't like
what's his name Harvey Weinstein doesn't
get to produce movies now that's just
cuz he doesn't go into jail I don't know
if he's going to jail or not yet but but
man that that article talked to me I
mean the [ __ ] that he did was just like
crazy like stuff that you were like oh
that's that it was worse than anything
you've read about guys like that -
anyway I don't know what the wolf
[ __ ] send the link out on the on the
congratulations podcast Twitter maybe
but I don't know what it is but I'll
find out and another thing that happened
in the world was the Miss America
eliminated hosing No eliminated sorry
it's the swimsuit thing which is like a
[ __ ] joke and women are like yeah but
you can still watch you could still see
that stuff if you want to just not on
that nobody watched Miss America for
anything but that women - okay guys
watched it
for pervy reasons and girls watched it
because they wanted to see their girls
of body okay you wanted to see how Miss
Atlanta looked in a [ __ ] swimsuit or
miss Vermont you know and then I put out
a tweet that was like hey that's like
when weightlifter is you and lemonade
let's eliminate way what I say something
about I forget what I said it was kind
of fine though it was it was no
groundbreaking [ __ ] but it was over
there just uh no but it wasn't that one
it was a Miss America eliminated the
swimsuit competition Jesus Jesus that's
[ __ ] Jesus that's [ __ ] hilarious
that's like weight lifters eliminating
posing in their competitions [ __ ] you
wanting [ __ ] now everyone was
like it's weightlifting you do
weightlifting you know I meant
bodybuilding you [ __ ] idiots let's
stop policing but yeah dude like do
something else that matters it's like
why were we why for a second were we
ever pretending like personalities
mattered on the [ __ ] Miss America
[ __ ] they did a little bit but all those
aunts the personality tell you something
when you ask those questions and their
personality and they're given the
answers that's more idiotic than them
just posing in bikinis they all give the
same [ __ ] generic answers about world
peace and helping children who they
don't even mean it they're just saying
dumb [ __ ] that's contrived and
regurgitated put on a [ __ ] swimsuit
and prance around this whole thing is
[ __ ] idiotic and I know it's on sex
is but the whole [ __ ] thing is sexist
period it's sexist without the [ __ ]
swimsuit it's stupid as [ __ ] the whole
thing is dumb as [ __ ] doesn't Donald
Trump [ __ ] have something to do with
it anyway one of them meet Miss Universe
it's like the whole thing's [ __ ]
stupid dude the
thing stupid let's try to act let's not
act like you're making it better when
the whole thing is stupid the whole
[ __ ] thing is stupid oh you're gonna
eliminate the swimsuits are cool much
better now thank God
that's like McDonald's having vegan
options just be McDonald's just be
[ __ ] McDonald's
let me get cancer here that's it oh you
know I just think that that's ridiculous
and I and the whole world does and
anybody who's acting like they don't
you're a holier than thou you know male
feminist trying to [ __ ] a girl that's
what you're trying to do oh good but
they don't have yeah this is one step
it's not one step to anything except
idiocy I don't know man look maybe I'm
[ __ ] completely wrong however now you
know that's a McDonald when McDonald's
has a McDonald's point does have vegan
options all [ __ ] okay I'll kill
myself when McDonald's has a vegan
options I don't know I just think it's
it's just I know we can only make we can
only help we can only do what we do to
make things better like it's not like
like people are like it's like oh yeah
people are like oh you know people are
starving out there what are you doing to
help yeah I get it I I'm not doing
anything to help that and I guess I'm
maybe I'm a piece of [ __ ] and I just
talk about it and you know I'm a
comedian and how does that help I guess
but like also
it seems silly to eliminate somehow it
seems silly to me to eliminate the the
swimsuit competition part of the Miss
America thing when like cops are like
beating the [ __ ] out of people unjustly
even though one doesn't have anything to
do with the other these whiny [ __ ]
these whiny [ __ ] liberals dude are are
just [ __ ] everything you're not even
the left anymore you're the right dude
oh we can't say this we can't do that
you're the right that has that is the
right that's conservative now you know
college is saying like oh well you can't
say this you can't do that we can't have
this speaker we can't have that speaker
feelings [ __ ] your feelings dude [ __ ]
your [ __ ] your feelings man for real
like like yo it's not it's no Judy gold
was saying it's not the you have to you
have to worry about your feelings it's
not the world that needs to change for
you you tickle [ __ ] do it oh
that hurts your feelings dude and by the
way by the way when you say oh we need
to change this because it hurts
Asians we're treating Asians like
they're [ __ ] babies dude they can
handle it you're supposing that they
can't handle it themselves when you put
a rule like oh we can't say this in
front of them you can't say that in
front of blacks you can't do this
because it hurts black people's feelings
it hurts Asians feelings that hurts
[ __ ] gays feelings dude they're grown
adults they can handle it
you [ __ ] liberal white whiny [ __ ]
it's not your job to babysit live your
[ __ ] life be a good person and don't
beat this [ __ ] at anybody don't beat
this [ __ ] anybody don't rape anybody
don't grab anyone by their [ __ ] and
just eat lunch eat dinner go to work and
go to sleep and have family time don't
touch anybody on their [ __ ] privates
don't [ __ ] anyone when they don't want
to and don't be too sure that anybody no
matter what color they are but stop stop
dude I saw all these [ __ ] you know I
get genders on a sliding scale but let's
just stop it somewhere dude
let's relax somewhere man I was on this
thread on Twitter that was like here are
all the genders and then the one person
and then though and then that at the end
it was like these are just some of them
remember there are billions of genders
hey dude the only thing that there are
billions of are billions of hairs on top
of Neil deGrasse Tyson's head there's
not billions of genders okay there's
some I don't even know how many there
are who knows people say no there's two
that's it all right I don't know you
know there's 10 all right whatever guess
what I don't even really give a [ __ ] but
let's stop babysitting everybody else if
there's billions of genders all right I
don't give a [ __ ] fine if you want to
identify as a lizard I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't care but guess what I'm gonna
make fun of you just like I'm gonna make
fun of every other thing I don't give a
[ __ ] and you're not gonna [ __ ] stop
me from doing it
stop relax chill you can identify as a
[ __ ] cloud but I'm gonna make and I
can make fun of it and that's it and
you're not gonna cry about it you're not
gonna cry about it or you are but I'm
not gonna give a [ __ ] remember the
of genders remember there's billions of
[ __ ] use no Shh everyone's gotta have a
flag you know what I mean
this is that I identify as a popsicle
flag
I don't know man
it's not about I say this all the time
it's not about what you say it's about
who you are everyone's getting in
trouble for what the [ __ ] they're saying
dude eliminating the swimsuit
competition is not the answer
oh we did a good thing we made it better
we're progressing we're not we're not
progressing dude this is not progression
this is going backwards you think that
this [ __ ] didn't already happened
[ __ ] thousands of years ago like
everything is all set
dude I was reading this book and it was
about how everything sexual is always
okay and not okay in the world at some
point in history like like gay sex is
forbidden in certain parts of the world
but also it's the way to be in other
parts of the world and everything always
changes like thousands of years ago in
[ __ ] whatever Mesopotamia or Greece
or wherever the [ __ ] it was it was
celebrated and now in that part of the
world
it's outlawed it's an N and it always
changes constantly no matter where the
[ __ ] you are in what time period you are
so it's like yeah I guess what I'm
trying to say is yeah just you know
relax and one fire Google's history of
homosexuality you know like that's gonna
that's gonna figure it out but it's oh
it's it's like I don't remember the
point I was trying to make because it
was - yeah I got I got wait I started
talking about [ __ ] that I don't know
about but like it's the truth
like
it's just how I'm getting a headache how
can we be so I just stop telling people
they can't do [ __ ] stop telling people
they can't do [ __ ] that's what it boils
down to stop making it so people can't
do [ __ ] period
we shouldn't be in charge of and
policing and babysitting who people can
[ __ ] who they can't [ __ ] and we
shouldn't be policing or babysitting
people who get their feelings hurt and
we shouldn't make rules about how we
can't say this we can't say that that's
it otherwise we're all the right I don't
know if there's some sort of left
universal left I guess that's what
everybody kind of thinks they want but
that idea is different for everybody so
we're [ __ ] so there's no universal
left so when it comes down to don't tell
people what they can and can't do period
of course we need laws religion ends up
[ __ ] everything up because all yeah
but I'm in my religion there's no gay
sex well you're a [ __ ] problem then
do it
you're a [ __ ] problem don't [ __ ]
anyone don't [ __ ] a guy if you don't
want to [ __ ] a guy but this is I'm not
saying anything that I'm [ __ ] any
smart person doesn't know already but
whatever just I guess when it comes down
to girls stuff as women stop referring
to your tits as the girls that's so
annoying that's what it all comes down
to stop callin hey how do the girls look
no you're a [ __ ] sad housewife Hey
No I'm so sweaty and so it's so hot in
this [ __ ] congratulations studios the
girls dude you know
hey how do the girls look in this top oh
no no no no no no no I don't have
anything else to say dude I have nothing
I'm done I don't want to [ __ ] it's
like this I'm just trying to get people
to come to my [ __ ] shows that's it
like that's what I want and so you have
this podcast where I talk [ __ ] and it's
like some of you guys show up and you
say bits from the podcast I don't even
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
dude
this [ __ ] is Oh dum dum dum dum dum this
is you this a magic couple right who
maybe I should Steppenwolf yep what 10
10 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 turn what
am I trying to do magic Harper right
whoops magic what's the magic carpet
ride one I don't know see he doesn't
know one fire did making it up he's just
going magic carpet ride magic carpet
ride oh yeah you are dude you know what
dude it's it man this is falling off the
rails it's okay I'm sweating my [ __ ]
ass off and I want to be done dude I'll
tell you what oh let's do Twitter
questions do we have that we have a
couple dude hey Chris D'Elia there's a
good one the log cabin from congrats LA
Kevin hey Chris Lea do you find it hard
to stay motivated doing podcasts without
the benefit of having the same instant
gratification stand-up provides first of
all sir about yeah I know I don't know I
mean I guess I got the to want
I got Ivan and Juan here so they you
know but now I would I do this because I
do what I think is funny I realize when
I'm onstage - I talk about it like I do
stuff that I think is funny and and the
audience happens to laugh and that's
great but I think
ultimately it comes from me anyway what
I think is funny so it works without it
but it is a little I don't know
sometimes I like it in a different way
than stand-up because I like to do I
like to talk about what I want to talk
about and I know there are no punchline
so I could just be free I guess and I do
that in stand-up as well too but I
always have that those punchlines that
could fall back on so good question
okay now I don't like when people get
cute like this here's this look a beep
at b-plus w7 do you like olives and
pickles
I must know no you don't you just trying
to be cute [ __ ] out of here you should
know I don't like that kind of [ __ ] oh
here we go
there's a good one Darien Boyd actress
Lea what do you think about people that
say me3 after someone says me too yeah
you know what I think about that do it
me three you're a school teacher if you
do that you're a [ __ ] school teacher
go shop and get the [ __ ] out of here
everybody was talking about everyone's
feeling my my is my friend was saying he
feels bad for LeBron dude because he
didn't win the [ __ ] the shut up dude
LeBron does fine LeBron's happy
LeBron lost and it's fine he is he the
greatest of all time yeah maybe um what
else any other questions so I hop is
just gonna change that [ __ ] huh that's
the ultimate [ __ ] and change it
that's the ultimate [ __ ] and change it
but why why I wonder they must be
hurting they must have to rebrand they
changed their Pete Oh Abbi that's some
what yeah people don't
[ __ ] about pancakes but I hop has stuff
people know but it's all about seed
we're idiots dude we see that pancake
and we're like oh it's got pancakes no I
probably do that people don't don't rush
for pancakes but they must have back
then when it started but people are more
health-conscious I feel like maybe is
that what it is but the burgers that
they haven't gonna be trashed - they -
yeah they probably didn't add anything
they probably just [ __ ] have
literally the same [ __ ] but changed to a
B and now people are gonna go because
they think they're healthy and still die
of cancer that's a good rebranding
though I was trying to think of
different rebranding things that happen
like you know it was such a good
branding thing was the most interesting
man in the world nobody knew what the
[ __ ] does SEC East was until that guy
came along and that [ __ ] was good that
was perfect for like that when the
internet was coming up and like that
[ __ ] it was like most interesting man in
the world killed it
anything else no all right well we're
gonna end this here
I got shows Square cash check out the
new boost rewards program get the cash
app and two rewards code congrats get $5
give $5 - times up and get it for iOS or
Android now that's square cash go
download that and while you're
downloading that download the Chris
D'Elia app so you can see the first 10
minutes of this podcast when we go live
follow the leader' tickets on sale at
Chris D'Elia calm
that's my tour going on follow the
leader I got coming up Miami Florida
West Palm Beach Jacksonville Atlanta Los
Angeles San Francisco Boston Fresno
Bakersfield Austin 9 San Antonio
Tulsa Oklahoma wood Midwest City
Oklahoma Dallas Portland Maine Hampton
Beach Mashantucket Houston Wichita
Kansas City Lincoln Reno Las Vegas
Ottawa Ontario London Ontario Buffalo
New York Burlington Vermont Philadelphia
Washington DC New York Montclair New
Jersey
that's my homecoming show Portland OR
Snoqualmie Washington change it and
Vancouver BC we have new stuff coming to
the store I think we're getting
restocked tomorrow and also we're
working on some new merch so look around
for that look out for that subscribe to
the YouTube channel new videos every
week
download the Chris D'Elia app we said
that and straight and subscribe this
show it really helps man I'm firing
corrigible white male black comic you
watch it like it really watch it
whatever the [ __ ] and thank you for
listening we got that alone together
show coming out soon I'm on a bunch of
episodes of that so check that out
that's on the freeform Network so thank
you guys and you guys are the best
[Music]
sayonara